The universe is incredibly big and seems full of potential for life.
With billions of habitable planets,
if an advanced civilization had the technology to travel between the stars at
just 0.1% of the speed of light,
it could colonize our galaxy in roughly 100 million years,
which is not that long. Given the billions of years, the Milky way has existed.
So in principle,
any space faring civilization should be able to spread rapidly over huge sectors
of the galaxy. And yet we see nothing, hear nothing.
The universe seems empty devoid of others.
This is the paradox which we've discussed in more detail. In other videos,
confronted with the seemingly empty universe. Humanity faces a dilemma.
We desperately want to know if we are alone in the Milky way.
We want to call out and reveal ourselves to anyone watching.
But that could be the last thing we ever do,
because maybe the is not empty.
Maybe it's full of civilizations, but they are hiding from each other.
Maybe the civilizations that attracted attention in the past were wiped away by
invisible arrows.
This is the dark forest solution to the fair paradox.
The way of life,
the hunter awakes in his hiding place and carefully listens for suspicious
noises from the thick undergrowth before he gets up,
another night has passed without incident.
The forest is dark and full of fog.
He considers calling out to others to end his loneliness,
but stops himself at the last moment. What if they are like him,
all living things seek to survive,
secure resources and multiply their greatest obstacle are
other living things that share the same objective competition between species
favored. The survival of beings with advantageous traits.
Our ancestors were inventive,
competitive expansionist and greedy for resources,
which led them to winning the competition for our planet today.
Most other animals are so utterly at our mercy that we wipe out about a dozen
species a day, just as an unintentional byproduct of how we like to run things.
But humans are more than individuals from us.
Cultures emerge that also compete with each other competitive and
expansionary cultures spread faster and further and merge with sub G
or destroy others.
If we look at our history, it becomes clear. We are dangerous,
not just to others, but also to ourselves.
Our human nature has driven us to take over every corner of our planet.
And soon we will look to the stars,
both to expand our domain and ensure access to evermore resources.
And then we might stumble upon others trying to do the same thing.
It's likely that the competition of life also takes place on far away
planets.
So it's logical to assume that an alien civilization that came to dominate their
planet would be in some regards similar to us.
But if they're similar to us, they too may be dangerous.
The implication
as the hunter sneaks through the dark forest to all alone,
he knows that there might be others like him. He can't know their intentions.
If they are aggressive or not,
the hunter knows he would kill to ensure his own survival.
So he has to assume that they would too.
And it might be that if he stumbles upon another hunter,
the one that she first survives,
none of this means that conflict is unavoidable so far.
The progress of the modern world seems to have made us more peaceful,
not more violent. Maybe this is true for other civilizations too,
that eventually progress means less conflict.
Not more different.
Alien civilizations also should vary from the mild and peaceful to the
malevolent and militaristic.
The existential problem we are facing is that when we meet others between the
stars,
we have no way of telling who is peaceful or aggressive and what their true
intentions are.
Similarly, they might not understand or trust our intentions,
even if we tell them that we are peaceful on top of that,
if we did discover another civilization and they discovered us the light years
between us would mean years of communication delay,
both sides would be in a state of uncertainty.
Wondering if the wisest move is to just attack because there's enough,
the serious issue, technological explosions, and the first strike advantage.
We don't know where the limits of technology are,
but we do know how much technological progress matters in war.
A few hundred or thousand years can turn conflict with uncertain results into
a one-sided massacre.
Seize as lesions would stand no chance against Napoleons army with their
cannons and Musks,
which would be eradicated by artillery from the first world war,
which would not stand a chance against today's drones and guided missiles.
So the power level of different civilizations may vary massively.
And even if not,
between the time us to detect another civilization and us saying hi,
we might already be hopelessly behind on the tech tree, which is bad enough,
but the nature of Anella conflict makes this worse.
If your opponent is light years away,
sending an invasion fleet takes so long that by the time it arrives,
it might be hopelessly obsolete.
So war between civilizations might be just about eliminating the other to remove
an existential threat to yourself, someone else who might be so scared of you,
that they attack the first chance they get in this environment.
The only way to guarantee a win is to strike with such force and speed that the
target has no chance of survival or time to counter attack or escape to seek
revenge later.
The stakes are the highest possible with no room for error.
If we assume that the majority of civilizations live on planet that use them
pretty vulnerable,
all you need to do is throw something massive at a planet to make it
uninhabitable.
So the ultimate interplanetary annihilation weapon is probably something like a
relativistic kill vehicle.
A missile shot at a planet is at a significant fraction of the speed of light.
For example, a missile, the size of a person, 95%,
the speed of light has as much energy as all nuclear bombs on earth.
If you shot a few dozen at the civilization you wanted to wipe out success would
be fairly certain. Even a single hit would suffice.
This is not that absurd of an idea.
A civilization only slightly above us on the Khe would have enough
energy to send multiple strikes against every planet its suspects of harboring
life. What makes these weapons?
So sinister is how much they favor a first strike since they would be so fast
that it might be impossible to protect yourself effectively against them.
Once they're launched conflict between civilizations may not be lengthy affairs,
but rapid winner takes all situations.
We're the first one to shoot wins.
This makes any civilization and existential threat to any other.
And if every civilization is an existential threat to every other,
there may be only two kinds of civilizations out there,
quiet ones and dead ones.
So what should we do? Should we worry?
It's unlikely that anybody has noticed humanity yet.
The radio signals we've transmitted in the last 100 years,
traveled a relatively tiny distance and have long decay into unreadable noise
at our technology stage. If we don't actively try to get noticed.
And if nobody specifically looks at our pretty unremarkable soda system,
we'll stay hidden.
But one day we will venture into space in a serious way and need to consider
these kinds of questions. Again,
we don't know if there are others or if we are going through the forest alone,
but we have no way of knowing for sure for the time being.
It seems the best we can do is to carefully listen.
And even if we see others step into a clearing and make themselves known,
we should not reply right away, but carefully watch them from the undergrowth.
Perhaps we are also thinking about this all wrong by allowing our primitive
brain that evolved in the context of the gruesome competition of life to conjure
fears of predatory aliens all around us.
Maybe the fact that we are looking at the universe like this is a sign that we
are not grown up yet as a species, the, there could be a friendly,
welcoming community of alien civilizations waiting to hear from us when we are
ready. As for now, the good news is there is actually little. We need to do.
We just need to be thoughtful about the signals we send out into the galaxy.
We need to watch the sky and learn more about our galaxy, our forest,
cuz whatever the nature of our forest is full of dangers or friends or
nobody at all.
Only careful observation can tell.
So let's do that at last,
the hunter reaches a clearing and finds a comfortable position.
So slowly the sun melts the fog away,
lost in thought he admires the vegetation until suddenly
he is eye to eye with another hunter frozen in terror,
just like himself. His mind is racing,
considering all the different options.
The hunter takes a deep breath and makes a decision.
Maybe the only way out of the dark forest is to step into
the clearing together.
And with this hopeful picture, we say goodbye to the year,
12,021 of the human air.
It was a wild year to say the lease still much more fun than 12,020.
Conza had its most successful month ever and published a book.
We tried a lot of new techniques and really got into blender and cinema 4d
hiding more and more 3d in our videos.
We have so many ideas for next year and big and ambitious plans
that we can't wait to share with you.
And all of this was and is possible because of your direct support.
Thank you so much. Kos GZA only works because of you.
So in tune with the end of the year,
we've designed a few products that will help you to visualize your place in the
universe.
Our very shiny,
the night sky poster shows you the little piece of space we can see from earth
with our own eyes or travel further out with our stellar zoom collection that
depicts our home in space for an increasing distance or dream with our space
themed notebooks, cynic posters, and pens.
We design and produce every single product with great care.
Getting something from our shop is the best way to support KO's Kaza.
We hope you have a wonderful end of the year and the 12,022 is more fun
and less exciting than the last two years. Thank you for watching.
Wait.